Speaker 1: We finally found one of these so-called
dead voters from the 2020 election.
Turns out it was a Republican voting under
the name of his deceased wife.
This has been one of the stories.
This is one of the stories we've been told
now for a very long time, but it really scaled
up with the November of 2020 election.
Dead people are voting now, not literally
dead people.
People who are dead are showing up as having
voted, and this is clearly some kind of major
fraud being perpetrated.
It's part of the theft of the election by
Joe Biden from Donald Trump now before even
analyzing and before telling you about the
story and before analyzing the broader data
around dead people voting.
It should be mentioned that even if their
claims were true of widespread dead people
voting, they would also have to show and prove
that it's happening in a way that helped Joe
Biden and hurt Donald Trump.
You could have 10000 so-called dead people
voting, but if it was 5000 dead people voting
for Trump and 5000 dead people voting for
Biden, it doesn't actually make a difference
in the election.
So absent from many of these discussions is
OK.
Part one is is it true?
But Part two, if true, is it happening in
a Partizan way where it would actually help
one candidate rather than the other?
The answer to all of the above is it's not
actually happening, and we're going to get
to that in a second.
But as is often the case with these stories,
the side shouting about the supposed fraud
in this case, dead people voting is the only
side that's getting caught doing it.
This is a story out of Nevada.
We previously mentioned this to you in a list
of examples of Republicans doing this.
He has now been sentenced Nevada man who voted
twice using dead wife's ballot.
Sentenced to probation.
And fined $2000.
This is Donald Kirk Hartl, who has accepted
a plea deal to avoid jail time.
A judge on Tuesday sentenced the Las Vegas
man to probation on a charge he voted twice
in the 2020 election by mailing in his deceased
wife's ballot.
The I-Team was first to report that Kirk Hartel,
55 years old, was facing two charges relating
to last year's election.
In court Tuesday, Hartl pleaded guilty to
one charge of voting more than once in the
same election.
He appeared virtually in court.
He was also fined two grand as part of the
plea agreement.
The original Category D felony carried a maximum
prison sentence of four years, gets probation
and two grand.
Ultimately, to me, this seems like a cheap
political stunt that backfired and shows our
voting system actually works because you were
ultimately caught.
That's what his that's what the judge in the
case said.
Rosemary Hartel died in 2017 at age 52 from
breast cancer.
Kirk Hartl is surviving husband A ballot for
Rosemary was issued in October and was received
by the county.
But Kirk said the ballot never came to his
house.
The I-Team found that even though Rosemary
died in 2017, her name appeared on the active
voter list.
Kirk Hartle says I would like to say I accept
full responsibility for my actions and regret
them, and I'm thankful for your consideration.
So we finally found the dead people voting
and it was a Republican.
Now this is an opportunity to remind you.
First of all, there are people writing to
me saying the punishment should have been
far stricter, should have been much, much
stricter punishment here for this guy.
OK, that's something that can be talked about.
We have data we have done.
There have been very good investigations done
into so-called dead people voting.
And it turns out that it's really easy and
popular to say 10000 people, 20000 30000 suspected
dead voters.
The BBC actually investigated this.
There was an initial claim from Republicans
that, for example, in Michigan, 10000 dead
people voted.
They had this list of 10000 people that were
dead.
The BBC did something very interesting.
They said, OK, from the 10000, let's pick
a random 30.
Let's just take 30 names at random.
And they started going through the 30 names.
In fact, they did 31 names out of the 31.
They spoke to 11 of the people and were able
to confirm they're still alive.
So random group of 31 supposedly dead voters,
11 are just straight up, still alive.
They found another 17.
They weren't able to speak to them, but there
was no record of their death.
There was no obituary.
There was no record anywhere.
That said, these people have died and were
able to find, although they didn't speak to
them.
Evidence that they were alive, either records
or other interactions with the public or government
system.
So that got them to 28.
And then they found three people who were
dead.
They were dead at the time that they checked.
When they looked into it, the three people
were two of the three were alive at the time
that they voted, meaning they didn't do anything
wrong.
OK, you could say, well, two of the people
died since sending their ballot shouldn't
be counted.
You can look at that.
And then one the last one was an error where
a juniors vote was counted as the senior imagine,
you know, David Pakman junior, although Jews
don't do the junior thing.
Imagine David Pakman David Pakman senior is
dead, David Pakman Junior is alive and votes,
and the vote is counted wrongly as if it was
David Pakman senior.
Still, only one vote, right?
It was counted as the wrong person, but it's
still only one vote.
That's what was found when BBC actually investigated
this.
So don't fall for the fact that it's happening
when it's not.
And more importantly, even if they were able
to prove that it's happening, they would also
have to prove that it's happening in a Partizan
way such that it would actually help one candidate
defeat another in even a single state, which
they've
not recognized.